hey there tone skaters and welcome back
to my channel
if this is your first time here i just
want to thank you so much for stopping
by it's really appreciated do me a huge
favor and hit that subscribe button as
that will help me out as i'm on the road
to monetization and i really appreciate
it right now the current goal is 500
we're taking baby steps and i'm almost
at 160. so help me out
also if you would like i would really
appreciate if you would hit the like
button as that will help me move through
the algorithm and if you can share this
with your fellow townscapers or youtube
friends to anybody that you think would
enjoy this content really it would
really help me out so today i wanted to
do the map tour for chapter seven
i hope you all enjoyed it it was a
two-parter session 25 and section 26. i
really had fun
building this you know it's uh it's one
of my favorite builds actually i really
have fun with this but anyways
uh i just want to thank you all for
viewing i hope y'all enjoyed it i'll
start doing chapter eight later this
week probably this weekend
um if you haven't seen sessions 25 and
26 you can find them in the upper right
corner
of the video they'll be in a card so
after you check this out you can
actually view me building this city
if you have already seen it i appreciate
you for viewing that um so before i let
you go again i just want to thank you so
much for supporting me this week we did
really well and i had a lot of fun
producing the content and i'm so glad
that y'all enjoyed it
um if you want to support me for
absolutely free there are two links down
in the description below where you can
do that
one link will take you back to my home
page and once you have clicked that link
and going back to my home page you have
supported me
um if you haven't subscribed then you
can subscribe at that point you can also
view me on the brave browser if you
don't have the brave browser that's the
second link in the description and when
you click that it'll take you to the
website you can download brave and you
can watch me for absolutely free and
that will help me out as well but of
course the most effective way to support
me is to hit the subscribe button and
i'll
really really appreciate it so again i
just want to say thank you for stopping
by
i really appreciated you guys uh without
y'all i wouldn't be doing my thang i
wouldn't have anybody viewing my video
so i really really appreciate it and i
just can't stress that enough but i'll
stop rambling and i will lead you to the
tour um thank you so much and i'll see
you guys next time
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
so
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
to
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Music]
two
[Music]
two
[Music]
two
[Music]
[Music]
hey there townscaper if you're hearing
this and that means you made it to the
end i just want to thank you so much for
viewing it's greatly appreciated make
sure you hit that subscribe button and
make sure you hit that like button
because that will help me out a lot
also you can follow me on instagram and
twitter the links are down in the
description below
and again i just want to say thank you
so much for checking in and i'll see you
next time
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
you